this video is brought to you by nordvpn
give yourself options online go to
nordvpn.com forward slash bio to get a
two-year plan with a huge discount plus
a bonus month more on them in just a bit
it has been over 50 years since a man
known only as bible john terrorized the
scottish city of glasgow with a
two-year-long killing spree the club
known as the barolan ballroom was
exclusive hunting ground he picked up
women danced with them and when the
night was done he would take them home
and strangle them just meters from the
safety of said home his crimes were
followed by the largest police operation
in the history of glasgow over 100
detectives worked the case collecting
over 50 000 statements and questioning 5
000 suspects trying to identify the
killer all of this proved to be in vain
bible john simply disappeared once his
murder spree had ended never to be heard
from again who he was why he did what he
did and why he stopped remain mysteries
to this day
the year was 1968 in glasgow scotland
patricia docker was a 25 year old
auxiliary nurse who had taken a young
son and moved in with her parents while
her husband was stationed at the royal
air force base near digby in
lincolnshire england on february 22nd
patricia decided that she wanted to let
her hair down a little things weren't
going too well for her her relationship
with her husband was on the rocks and
the couple had already talked about
getting a divorce their job got pretty
intense as pat worked night shifts at
one of the busiest hospitals in the city
that was why for one night she wanted to
put all of her problems aside and enjoy
some me time that thursday evening pat
had the day off so she left her
four-year-old son in the care of his
grandparents she dressed up in one of
her most fashionable outfits a yellow
mini dress accessorized with a brown
handbag to match her shoes all of this
was covered by a large duffle coat with
a fur collar fashion is nice and all
that but this is still a winter's night
in scotland once she was ready pat hit
the town for a night of dancing drinking
and maybe even some casual flirting
little did she know that she would
become involved in the largest manhunt
in the city's history back then if you
were young and you were looking for a
good time in glasgow you went to the
majestic that's where pat's parents
thought she was going but it was not
where she actually went she might have
stopped there originally but for reasons
that remain unknown she ended up at the
barrel and ballroom which was hosting an
over 25s night one dancehall is as good
as another right well unfortunately for
patricia docker this dance hall was the
hunting grounds for a violent predator
and he was there that night
looking for prey munchie was inside the
dancehall it becomes pretty much
impossible to track pat's movements as
she became just another figure in the
crowd vibing to the sounds of the
swinging 60s she said hello to a few
friends danced with a few people had a
few drinks what you would expect to
happen on a night out but at one point
she did meet a man he was in his mid to
late 20s well groomed with either
reddish or light brown hair and handsome
enough to catch pat's attention the two
talked a little danced a little and they
left maryland together that was the last
time that anyone saw patricia docker
alive the following morning a tablet
maker named maurice goodman left his
house and was walking the short journey
to the lock-up garage where he kept his
car when he suddenly came across a
ghastly sight that would haunt him
forever it was the body of patricia
docker partially naked beaten and
bruised lying in the doorway of the
garage goodman rushed to call the cops
and two detectives were soon on the
scene the police pathologist arrived
shortly after them and provided the
first clues of the investigation based
on rigor mortis pat had been murdered
hours earlier most likely a short time
after leaving the barylan ballroom she
had been hit in the face and head
mercilessly although none of these
injuries would have been life
threatening instead she was killed by
strangulation most likely with a belt or
pantyhose the murder weapon was never
recovered and neither were the rest of
pat's clothes the medical examiner noted
that pat docker was menstruating at the
time of her death although no importance
was placed on that fact
yet police began canvassing the
neighborhood but did not turn up any
useful leads one neighbor thought that
they had a cry for help during the early
hours of the morning but they didn't
bother to get up and check so that was a
dead end police did id the body pretty
fast does one of the ambulance men
recognize pat as a nurse who worked at
the mernskirk hospital her parents were
alerted to the tragedy and her father
made the official identification from
then on it was slim pickings for
investigators the time they saved with
the id they lost by making inquiries the
majestic since that was where they
thought patricia docker went that night
eventually they found out that she ended
up at the barylan ballroom instead and
that she left with a young man who was
most likely her killer but that was
about it nobody seemed to remember
anything remarkable about him and those
who did might not have been too eager to
talk you see the maryland was the kind
of place where many guests took off
their wedding rings by accident and
forgot that they were married for a few
hours which could potentially explain
why pat docker and probably many others
preferred to tell their loved ones that
they went somewhere else to spend their
evening truth be told the crime might
not have been the police's highest
priority at the time glasgow was quite a
violent place back then with a murder
rate there was over double that of other
big cities like edinburgh london police
thought this was a straightforward and
isolated crime of passion a man picked
up a woman at a club and when she
rebuffed his advances he attacked her
they did not yet know that they were
investigating the first murder of the
man who had become known as scotland's
most notorious unidentified killer so
when leads dried up they moved on to
another case that is until he struck
again
[Music]
almost a year and a half passed before
the killer claimed another victim by
this point most of glasgow had quietly
forgotten about the murder of patricia
docker and nobody suspected that the
city had a vicious serial killer in its
midst but then on august 16 1969 a
familiar scenario occurred to remind
everyone of the dangers that lurked
within the shadows of glasgow jemima
mcdonald was a 32 year old mother of
three who liked to let loose every now
and then just like pat dawker when the
time came for a little carousing she
left her children with her sister and
went to the maryland ballroom where she
was somewhat of a regular because of
this several people spotted her in the
dance hall that night and they also
noticed that she was getting very
friendly with a guy whose description
matched that of pat docker's final
companion a tall man in his late
twenties early thirties slim build well
dressed well groomed he was sporting a
blue suit and reddish hair winders also
said that he spoke with a glaswegian
accent and overheard him making several
biblical references which would
ultimately end up giving him his unique
moniker in the press they even had a
first name for him john although it was
most likely an alias it appeared that
jemima macdonald was quite infatuated
with a new consort and the two left
baryland together shortly after midnight
the following morning her sister
margaret got worried when she saw that
jemima had not returned home that night
her worry soon turned to panic when she
heard the local scuttlebutt that some
neighborhood kids were going around
telling everyone that they discovered a
dead body in an abandoned tenement
building just yards from her house
margaret went there to check if the
rumor was true or if kids were just
being kids and her findings confirmed
her worst fear the body was real
and it belonged to her sister jeremiah
macdonald had been ferociously assaulted
and then strangled to death just like
with patricia docker the body was found
close to her home and her handbag was
missing although unlike the first victim
jemima macdonald had not been stripped
naked even though the attack was eerily
reminiscent of the one on patricia
docker the police were not quite ready
to attribute them both to the same
culprit since two different murderers
frequenting the same nightclub within a
year and a half times ban would not have
been unheard of that being said they
also didn't rule out the possibility so
they stepped up their efforts to find
him this time they sent undercover
officers to the dancehall they had one
policewoman dress up as jemima mcdonald
and retrace her last known steps to see
if it jogged anyone's memory they even
released a sketch of the suspect to the
public which was a first for a scottish
murder investigation since back then
these were only circulating among police
organizations all of this effort turned
up nothing police did not get any closer
towards catching their man although to
be fair the culprit did not wait around
too long before he killed again all
right we'll get back to our video in
just a second but first here's a word
from today's video sponsor nordvpn look
everybody uses the internet slightly
differently and that's totally fine but
you don't want to do is use the internet
unprotected you may have heard me talk
about what nordvpn can do for you
previously encrypt your internet data
and move your online activity to another
location with just a single click either
for security or streaming all that is
still true nor vpn has more than 5 000
servers throughout 60 countries but vpns
give you access to so much more than
just new tv shows like what if you want
to buy a video game that's cheaper
somewhere else or maybe not even
available in your country well use
nordvpn having trouble connecting to
social media nordvpn want to root your
connections through multiple servers
just for double layered security yes
totally possible with nordvpn right now
as a special deal you guys can get a
two-year plan at a huge discount plus
one free month and if you try nord and
change your mind they offer a 30 day
money back guarantee all you've got to
do is head to nordvpn.com forward slash
bio again nordvbn.com forward slash bio
for a two-year deal at a huge discount
plus a free month or just follow the
link below and now back to today's video
[Music]
this time only a couple of months had
passed before the mysterious killer
decided to paint the town red once more
it was october 31 1969 halloween night
so unsurprisingly there were quite a few
parties taking place throughout glasgow
many people hit the town to celebrate
and among them was helen partook a 29
year old mother of two her husband
volunteered to stay home with a kid so
his wife could go out and enjoy a night
out although he was a bit apprehensive
by that point the idea that there was a
killer among them stalking the streets
of glasgow at night put some of the
locals on edge but no need to worry
though helen reassured her husband she
was going out accompanied by her sister
jean and the two of them would look
after each other so with that mata
settled helen got dressed up and went
out her destination the maryland
ballroom according to jean she and helen
paired off with two men who both
introduced themselves as john and spent
most of the night dancing with them when
it was time to go all four of them left
together the harmless john traveled on
foot to a nearby bus station while the
sisters and the evil john got into a
taxi together the following experience
was either innocuous or sinister
depending on who you ask i mean in
hindsight it was absolutely sinister the
two sisters were sharing a ride with a
serial killer after all but according to
one book on the subject that three of
them spent the time mostly talking about
trivial things and when gene was the
first to reach her destination she felt
like she was leaving helen in safe hands
another book however paints a much
darker picture and says that john was
morose even upset during the whole trip
resenting gene's presence he spent the
time talking about the evils of dens of
iniquity such as the parallel ballroom
and chastised the women of loose morals
who frequented such places even so
john's off-putting behavior wasn't
enough to raise any serious alarm bells
so when gene got out of the cab and
waved goodbye to helen she had no idea
that that would be the last time she'd
see her sister alive helen puddik's body
was found the next morning by a man
walking his dog she had been dumped in a
courtyard once again close to where she
lived she had been strangled her clothes
had been ripped and her handbag had been
taken like the previous two victims
helen was menstruating at the time of
her death police had noticed this with
the other women but thought it was
simply a coincidence now however the
killer took time to make a clear
reference to this fact by taking one of
her sanitary pads and placing it under
her armpit could it be that this was
some kind of trigger for him that
unleashed his murderous rage that wasn't
the only difference between the crime
scenes there were a few other signs that
as the killings continued the culprit
was starting to get either more careless
or was losing his ability to control his
violent urges he left a deep bite mark
on helen's body and also a semen stain
on her clothes nowadays those would be
viable forensic clues but it was still
the 1960s so there wasn't a lot that the
police could do with them even so the
investigators preserved the evidence in
the hopes that it would become more
useful in the future
with three murders of similar victims
who were all picked up in the same place
most likely by the same man there could
be no more doubt glasgow had a serial
killer on his hands the press picked up
on the murderer's habit of quoting
scripture and gave him the notorious
sobriquet bible john that kicked the
police investigation into high gear and
with all hands on deck everyone was
hopeful that bible john would soon be
behind bars after all he left plenty of
witnesses behind including helen's
sister gene who had spent a whole cab
ride with him and there were other
people who spotted him at baryland as
well the official description provided
by the police to the press described
bible john as a man of medium build
around six feet tall 25 to 30 years of
age with short light reddish hair and
blue gray eyes with one tooth in the
upper right corner of the mouth
overlapping another tooth and sporting a
military military-style watch
investigators even circulated a detailed
color portrait of the killer made by an
artist from the glasgow school of art
unsurprisingly the sketch opened the
floodgates and the tip started pouring
in at torrential speed over 4 000 people
contacted the police just in the days
that followed claiming to know someone
who resembled the portrait eventually
investigators began issuing special
cards to the innocent men who had been
questioned and cleared of charges just
so that they could prove to their loved
ones and co-workers that they weren't
bible john a profile compiled by a
psychiatrist in 1970 described john as a
sex killer appeared and acted like the
sort of young man that a mother would
want her daughter to bring home he was
good at hiding his evil side from those
close to him and on the exterior he
appeared shy and harmless he was a loner
who preferred solo activities opting to
go alone to the cinema over going out
with a group to drink or watch a game he
possessed many of the traits often found
in compulsive sex killers such as
tidiness vanity high intelligence
effeminacy and a dislike of smoking
drinking and vulgar language he probably
still lived with his mother who saw him
as nothing but a sweet little boy even
though he secretly harbored a hatred of
women which compelled him to exert his
power over them and
ultimately murdered them for a while
there was this belief that the killer
attended clubs even when he didn't
murder anybody then on certain night
something happened that triggered his
compulsion to kill therefore 16 officers
were assigned to dance duty every night
they would go out undercover at the
baryland and other dancehalls and boogie
until the wee hours of the morning in
the hopes that they might run into bible
john on the dance floor another strange
lead came from a witness who remembered
having a casual chat with a killer about
golf where john mentioned that his
cousin had recently scored a hole in one
this was all the info the police had to
go on but they still reached out to all
the 400-plus golf courses in scotland to
see if anyone remembered such a feat
being celebrated recently cabbies and
bus drivers in glasgow were all tracked
down and questioned if they recognized
the portrait dentists were asked if any
of them could identify bible john based
on the overlapping tooth an appeal was
made to the armed forces since the
killer's wristwatch and short hairstyles
suggested he could have been a military
man one by one each lead was pursued and
one by one each lead had a dead end
although at first police were hopeful
that identifying and catching bible john
was only a matter of time that hope was
dwindling with every passing day
[Music]
it's probably not much of a spoiler to
tell you that the police never caught
bible john the killer seemingly vanished
after the murder of helen potter and was
never heard from again he became a
boogeyman a distant memory of terror
that once lurked in the shadow similar
to other notorious killers such as jack
the ripper or the zodiac but although
the bible john murders became a cold
case it was never officially closed
obviously the 100 detectives who once
worked on the case were reassigned once
the clues had dried up but they still
pursued new leads whenever they appeared
helen's sister jean still came in
whenever there was a new suspect to look
at she never publicly discussed her
sister's murder but she was available
whenever the police needed her gene made
around 250 such trips to the station but
none of them ever ended with her
pointing a finger at a suspect and
saying that's him that's the man that
killed my sister there was some renewed
zeal for the investigation during the
1990s when dna analysis became the new
forensic darling glasgow police still
had the semen samples from the putting
murder but the samples on their own
would be useless without something to
match them up against police wanted to
test dna from one of their strongest
suspects a man known back then as simply
john m who had committed suicide in
1980. he seemed like a good fit he had a
very strong resemblance to the bible
john sketch and he used to serve in the
armed forces as part of the scots guard
as the investigation continued through
the years he kept popping up on top of
the suspect pile so in 1996 the police
obtained an exclamation order for his
body the operation was supposed to be
discreet but the name of the suspect
leaked out and all of a sudden the
scottish press were all over it deeming
john mcinnes to be bible john before the
results even came in on top of that the
police were pressured to justify why
exactly the exclamation and dna test
ended up costing over a million dollars
and overall the whole thing turned into
one big pr nightmare then the coup de
grace was delivered when the results
came in and they cleared john mcinnes of
any involvement leaving crown
investigators with a lot of egg on their
faces as they issued a very prolonged
and public apology to the mcginnis
family but the way they bungled it so
one of the main suspects in the case was
off the table but even worse the debacle
had caused the authorities to be a lot
more apprehensive about trying it again
the sad reality was that the murders of
bible john had long been replaced by
newer even more horrifying crimes so it
was a matter of allocating resources
where they would be most effective that
being said there were rumblings around
2005 that glasgow police had collected
dna samples from a new family in order
to match them that time however their
name didn't get out since no public
statements on the matter were ever made
we can only presume the results were
negative but let's get to the main event
peter tobin if you are familiar with the
bible john case at all then you know
that name already for the last 15 years
or so he has been presented by many
people as the best candidate to be bible
john let's start with the obvious here
peter tobin is a convicted serial killer
who murdered at least three young women
between 1991 and 2006 but since he was
already in his mid-40s by the time he
committed his first known murder police
suspected that there might be earlier
victims thus operation anagram was born
in 2006 but the goal being to track
tobin's movements as far back as
possible to see if there were links to
any previous murders that's when the
bible john connection popped up since it
was revealed that tobin lived near
glasgow at the time of the baryland
killings and would have been in his
mid-20s he moved to england the same
year the murders stopped after marrying
for the first time furthermore tobin
came from a strict religious family and
his first wife once said that he
attacked her after becoming enraged
because she was menstruating a lot of
fingers were starting to point in
tobin's direction but dna couldn't help
us anymore by the time of his arrest the
samples from the 1960s became too
degraded to produce conclusive results
to this day plenty of people are still
convinced that he is bible john however
the detectives who worked on operation
anagram are not among them and they say
that they've eliminated tobin as a
suspect pretty conclusively insisting
that he wasn't in glasgow at the time of
some of the murders so for now bible
john remains as elusive as ever so i'm
not gonna ask if you enjoyed today's
video but if you enjoy this sort of
crime content i actually have a entire
show dedicated to true crime it's called
the casual criminalist we do a full
extended super long episode all about
bible john which i'll link to on the
screen now you can check out there'll be
a link below as well and well check it
out please subscribe if you like it and
thank you for watching
[Music]
you